Hi zusammen! Heute gibt es die leckerste Maxi King Torte überhaupt
und dafür brauchen wir jetzt zuallererst Vanille Biskuitboden!
Und kauft ihn euch nicht fertig! Macht ihn euch einfach selber, da geht super easy.
Nach meiner Anleitung und meinem Rezept gelingt er euch 100%ig.
Ich hab vorab die Eier getrennt, Eiweiß und Eigelb - Natürlich, wie soll man sie auch sonst trennen?
Da habe ich dann mein Eiweiß in eine fettfreie Schüssel gegeben.
Ich benutze heute meine Küchenmaschine. Es würde auch ein Handrührgerät funktionieren aber hier wird -
Hier wird wirklich viel gerührt, auch nachher und so weiter daher benutze ich die Küchenmaschine.
Geb' da jetzt 'ne Prise Salz mit dazu
und schlage das Ganze jetzt für ungefähr bis zu 1min auf maximaler Geschwindigkeit.
Dann werdet ihr merken, dass sich das Volumen richtig verdoppelt und verdreifacht.
Und dann geben wir die Hälfte des Zuckers mit dazu,
schlagen noch weitere 3min und haben dann unsere Baisermasse.
Das hört sich so wahnsinnig kompliziert an, ist aber super, super easy!
Oh! Ich hab vergessen, den Stecker rein zu machen!
So!
Sobald die Baisermasse dann fertig ist, einfach die Schüsseln austauschen
und das Eigelb mit dem restlichen Zucker und Vanillezucker für ungefähr 4min richtig schön hell-cremig schlagen.
Und das Ergebnis kann sich echt sehen lassen! Also schön hell-cremig, fluffiiiig....
Ah, gut dass ich eine Schürze anhab! Guck, ist auf meiner Schürze gelandet!
[Hamza] *lacht*
Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen Teigschaber.
Das kann euch jetzt keine Maschine mehr ersetzen denn jetzt kommt die Baisermasse
mit ganz viel Liebe und in mehreren Schritten hier unter die Eigelbmasse.
Das zeige ich euch jetzt mal.
Sobald das erledigt ist, kommen die trockenen Zutaten ins Spiel.
Da nehme ich mir jetzt ein Sieb und gebe Mehl, Speisestärke und Backpulver dazu.
Und das auch unterheben und am besten ebenfalls in mehreren Schritten.
So, der Biskuitteig ist jetzt fertig.
Den Backofen müsst ihr übrigens immer vorheizen, das ist ganz ganz wichtig!
Und zwar auf 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und dadurch, dass ich jetzt eine 26cm große Springform nehme, braucht er bei mir 40min.
Aber nicht jeder Backofen backt gleich, deswegen macht auch ruhig nach 38min mal die Stäbchenprobe
und wenn am Stäbchen - also am Schaschlikspieß nix hängen bleibt, dann ist der Teig gar.
So, während der Biskuitboden gerade im Backofen vor sich hin backt, machen wir Karamell
denn zu einer Maxi King Torte gehört natürlich eine ordentliche Portion Karamell!
Natürlich könnt ihr auch fertige Karamellsoße nehmen aber ich zeige euch, dass ihr das ganz easy zuhause machen könnt!
Ich habe hier meine beschichtete Pfanne.
Ich nehme die mit dem hohen Rand weil gleich kommt ein Prozess,
da schäumt es hoch und da gehe ich lieber auf Nummer sicher!
Und die habe ich jetzt hier auf mittlerer Stufe erwärmt und da gebe ich jetzt weißen Zucker rein.
Schön verteilen und ab jetzt eigentlich rühren oder so
sondern nur warten, dass es schön langsam karamellisiert.
Und ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Je dunkler das wird nachher,
also je bräunlicher es wird, umso bitterer schmeckt das Karamell.
Deswegen sehe ich zu, dass es bei mir nicht ganz so dunkel wird.
Sobald der Zucker geschmolzen ist - bei mir hat das ca. 9min gedauert -
geben wir Butter mit dazu, lassen das kurz schmelzen
und anschließend in einem Schwung die Sahne mit dazu.
Da dürft ihr euch nicht wundern: das schäumt jetzt richtig doll.
Dann muss das Ganze quasi nur noch 1min lang köcheln und ihr merkt wenn ihr später auch den Schneebesen benutzt,
dass sich das Ganze richtig schön verbindet.
Und jetzt ist es bei mir schon ein bisschen abgekühlt, es darf aber noch ruhig ein bisschen mehr abkühlen!
Und dann brauchen wir das nämlich gleich erst, das gebe ich jetzt nämlich kurz an die Seite.
In der Zwischenzeit ist mein Biskuitboden auch fertig gebacken.
Hier habe ich noch einen kleinen Tipp für euch:
Ihr könnt hier einfach Küchenrolle nass machen unterm Wasserhahn, auswringen
und dann komplett auf die Oberfläche geben, dann kann er euch auch nicht austrocknen.
Der ist jetzt noch nicht ganz so kühl, der muss jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter kühlen
aber ich mache in der Zwischenzeit schon mal die leckere Haselnuss-Sahne Creme.
Dafür habe ich hier kalte Schlagsahne, die kommt ganz frisch ausm Kühlschrank und die muss auch sehr, sehr kalt sein!
Das schlage ich jetzt auf. Da schlage ich das Ganze an, gebe nachher Sahnefest dazu und lass das komplett steif schlagen
So, die Sahne ist jetzt steif, es geht weiter mit unserer Mascarpone.
Und wie gesagt, ich schreibe euch alle ganz Grammangaben hier unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Das Praktische ist: Ihr könnt euch dann einen Screenshot machen und alles direkt einkaufen gehen.
So und hier zur Mascarpone gebe ich jetzt Puderzucker.
Ich hab den Zuckeranteil allerdings schon sehr stark reduziert.
Also es wird so 'ne angenehme Süße.
Das wird jetzt keine mächtige Torte sondern einfach 'ne leckere Maxi King Torte!
Da kommt jetzt meine Haselnusscreme ins Spiel!
Ich hab euch ja schon vorab verraten, dass ich damit das ein oder andere zubereiten werde
und hier braucht ihr euch auch keine Sorgen machen, dass dann durch die Creme irgendwie die Konsistenz flüssig wird oder sowas.
Überhaupt nicht, da habe ich hier drauf geachtet!
Und das gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit zur Mascarpone.
Dann rühren wir das ganz kurz, sodass sich alles miteinander verbindet
und geben anschließend mit dem Teigschaber die Sahne mit dazu.
So! Perfekt, perfekt, perfekt!
Ich geb' jetzt noch die Sahne dazu und dann wird's richtig fluffig!
So, einmal mit meiner Winkelpalette den Rand gelöst
und jetzt schneiden wir den Tortenboden durch 3, schön gleichmäßig!
Jetzt muss ich hier einmal die Springform wegnehmen.
Und ich bin ganz ehrlich zu euch: Eigentlich ist es sau schwierig, einen so frischen Tortenboden durchzuschneiden
aber ich habe ja da die spezielle Tortensäge!
Nicht mit Draht sondern mit 'ner richtigen Klinge und da dürfte das eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Also normalerweise würd' sie euch richtig zerbrechen aber ich bin mir sicher, hier passiert jetzt nix.
Jetzt muss ich nur gucken..
[Hamza] Jetzt hast du aber große Töne gespuckt, du!
Da mache ich mir jetzt auch gar keine Sorgen! Ich muss sie nur kurz einstellen weil ich guck grad, wie hoch der geworden ist.
Gib mir mal ne Sekunde!
[Hamza] *lacht* Jetzt kommt die Teigkarte, die misst das aus!
Jetzt kommt meine Teigkarte!
Hmm... Ja, wie immer halt, ne? 4 ½ cm hoch!
So 1 ½ cm und jetzt säge ich einmal durch.
Ah, jetzt habe ich dich angeguckt statt in die Linse!
[Hamza] Komm du Baumfäller!
Jetzt säge ich einmal durch!
[Hamza] Jetzt sind wir aber gespannt, ne Kiki?
Ja..Guck, perfekt! Sage ich doch!
Der ist sogar noch warm in der Mitte. Ich lasse den jetzt so nochmal kurz auskühlen.
Bist du bereit für die beste Nachricht des Tages?
[Hamza] Welche?
Du wirst es sofort merken!
[Hamza] Ich weiß es nicht!
[Hamza] Was ist denn los?
Moment, Moment, gleich realisierst du's! Nimm mich ruhig auf, gleich realisierst du das!
[Hamza] Aaah, ich kann die Reste essen! Aah!
[Kiki] Jaa!
Reste essen!
[Hamza] Reste esseeen!
So, jetzt habe ich 3 komplett gleichmäßige Böden.
Der ist noch ein bisschen warm aber wir machen danach sofort weiter!
Ich hab' mir jetzt hier meine Tortenplatte geholt,
werd da gleich meinen Tortenring drumherum legen und dann fangen wir an zu schichten!
Der Rest geht wirklich Schlag auf Schlag, das geht jetzt ganz schnell!
Irgendwie fand ich die weiße doch passender, ich hab jetzt die weiße Tortenplatte genommen.
[Hamza] *lacht* Typisch Frauen!
So und jetzt die Torte Schritt für Schritt schichten!
Das heißt immer einen Boden, dann etwas von der Creme
und on top gebe ich auch noch ein bisschen von meinem selbstgemachten Karamell.
Und wenn ich oben angekommen bin, kann ich auch schon mit meinem Backformlöser den Tortenring entfernen.
Und jetzt habe ich noch 1/3 der Creme übrig und die verstreiche ich rundherum. Das heißt an der Oberfläche und an den Seiten.
Und jetzt geht's eigentlich nur noch um die Dekoration, dass wir sie so schmackhaft wie möglich aussehen lassen!
Ich nehme dafür Haselnusskrokant um so einen Abschluss für den Rand zu finden,
gebe dann mein selbstgemachtes Karamell on top und natürlich Maxi King Stückchen.
Und dann könnt ihr euch überlegen, ob ihr da noch ganze Nüsse oder auch Haselnusskrokant nochmal on top gebt
oder einfach alles, worauf ihr Lust habt!
[Kiki] So, ein bisschen Karamell noch on top..
[Hamza] Kamarell!
Ein bisschen Kamarell!
Ja, 2 Eis mit Kamarell!
So, ein bisschen Haselnusskrokant..
Wobei ich das eigentlich eigentlich gar nicht mehr notwendig finde!
Ich find' die so perfekt!
Ich sag euch nochmal ganz kurz was zur Haltbarkeit, die Frage wird bestimmt kommen!
Ihr könnt sie auf jeden Fall am Vortag komplett fertig machen.
Sie hält insgesamt 3 Tage lang.
Kühlt sie halt mal immer über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
Und ihr könnt sie auch sofort anschneiden. Aber ich rate euch, sie mindestens für 30min zu kühlen,
dann sitzt nochmal alles schön!
Und wenn ihr sie auch am Vortag vorbereitet, ist das auch nochmal ein kleiner Vorteil,
dass die Feuchtigkeit richtig in die Böden eindringt.
Die sind zwar schon sehr fluffig aber durch das Eindringen der Flüssigkeit
oder der Feuchtigkeit besser gesagt, wird's nochmal so richtig weich!
Also: Unbedingt nachmachen! Ich glaub' mehr muss ich heute dazu gar nicht sagen!
Wenn euch das Rezept gefallen hat, dann freue ich mich über einen Daumen nach oben natürlich
und ein kostenloses Abo wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan habt.
Und ansonsten schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare, welche Süßigkeit ich als nächstes als Torte verbauen soll
und dann machen wir das. Oder?
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall!
*beide lachen*
Also ich wünsche euch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Rezept hier auf meinem Kanal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
Und der Hamza hinter der Kamer- okay!
[Hamza] Ja okay! Ich glaube das wissen die Leute jetzt!
[Kiki] Das wissen die Leute!